Hello, this is Dr. Conner's. I hope you're getting something you do look at my disease
And I hope this is beneficial for you. This is
Presentation number nine for section number nine
The section that you're reading in this book again
the book that you're reading the
Download that you're getting is
Expanded from the book cover that you're looking at if you ordered on
Amazon now. Why am I telling you that?
Because I'm not going to sell as many books. I don't care. I just want you to get better. So
We're constantly adding to the information
So we're going to review the process here a lot to go through. I understand three phases of line a cute face
If I does it still within the cell or excuse me still within the blood or in the extra cellular spaces and you want to
By all means catch it in that window chronic is that it's entered into a cell
Though it is not yet turned into an autoimmune disease an autoimmune you're higher typically in a TH1 dominance with live disorder and you are
Have created antibodies against your own tissue
So TH1 dominant patients have to consider
Altered it ways to treat the disease because every time they stimulate in a viewed response, they might feel better for a couple days
And then they'll just crash. So it just doesn't work that way. So there's a bunch of different
done
TH1 stimulators that I wrote about in this section of the book
My favorite is you see the rife so matter of fact we will not even take an autoimmune patient a rife patient without
them
buying a rife and using it at home
So our protocol is they go home with a rife machine and they're using it every single night
I program it specifically to their body. So in our plans
Autoimmune line patient is in our office for two days two full days while we do a complete workup with them figure out
Exactly what we're going to do from a dutersutical standpoint and also from a frequency standpoint
Intestine them exactly what their program is and I personally write their programs. So we do that with cancer patients as well
always with
Light patients they go home with brain therapies
Very very important because if you don't rebuild those pathways
So I just touched on this the last presentation, but it really is very very important
You have damaged neurological pathways. We need to rebuild those pathways and the only way to do that is with
Brain therapies. It is doable. That's called neuroplasticity. So
we need to
If you just remove the inflammation, it's like having a flood that damages the roadway
You the flood waters recede you have to rebuild the roadway. So that's the brain therapies
So we need to get the flood waters to recede that's killing the line and then we need to rebuild the the highways
That's the different brain therapies. So very important in our office
Read this. I'm not going to pause it if you have to read it. We would over it multiple times. So
The next presentation we're going to go deeper into the right for sheet and it will be
Hopefully very beneficial for you. All right. I'll see you at the next section